Let's go next to our caller from the two five,
six area code.
Who's calling today from two five, six.
Uh, Ian.
Hey, what's up?
Can you hear me?
Uh, fantastic.
Uh, so a lot of time.
First time pleasantries.
Thank you.
Um, when I was in college, I went to a party
and there were some hippies there and they
basically laid out the argument and the critique
that, uh, from, um, uh, confessions of an
economic Hitman, you know, criticizing the
IMF and, um, how international loans foreign
aid doesn't actually do the thing that we
say that it does.
But yes, I'm a chapels the eighties, and we're
the good guys.
And of course everything we do is fine.
But like now, Oh no, that, that's not true.
And there are people like Richard Wolf, uh,
Nick Hannah, uh, Nick Hanauer with this record,
economics, new economic thinking and all of,
uh, you know, the kind of pothole issues kind
of boil down to what's going on in your wallet.
The economy's stupid.
So, um, and I just saw a thing tweeted this
morning about how, uh, MSNBC had this, um,
kind of like infomercial almost about like,
Oh, right.
We actually do kind of have these, uh, demo,
uh, social democratic policies incorporated
in the United States.
So I wonder, because you have a much wider
audience than I have and you're communicating
regularly, are, are you finding that the tide
is turning as you're going from place to place,
that the kind of standard narrative of like
Mirka F yeah.
Like is it starting to change?
Are you saying within the United States or
in other countries?
Oh, I know it's other countries.
I've been to other countries before, like
they had like, what are you doing?
What are you guys doing?
Yeah.
Um, the, the internal perception of, you know,
uh, USA ID and when we give food to Haiti,
that it actually just collapses there, uh,
the farming economy and makes it difficult
for them to, so like, I know that I've got
a degree in economics, like I see how this
works, but when I tell people, Oh, I have
a degree in economics, it seems to like, um,
increase the distance as opposed to narrow.
Oh, I see what you're saying.
Here's my view on this.
So I do think that some of the, so what you're
basically talking about is getting away from
some of what has some of what has been the
conventional wisdom around how to support
other countries and improve other countries
and foreign aid and so on and so forth.
I do think that there are important alternative
voices now that are saying a lot of the things
we thought made sense don't make any sense.
You know, if you go to a country where people
don't have shoes and you just give them a
bunch of free shoes that were manufactured
in Malaysia
for an American company and you go to someplace
in South America and give a community shoes,
you're not really bolstering their local economy
in the way that we thought.
You're not developing industry, you're just
giving them a pair of shoes.
And when that pair of shoes wears out, then
they'll still not have a shoe industry and
they'll ha right.
So, so we are getting a better understanding
of that.
The one thing that is interesting about that
is that a lot of those analyses are often
based on relatively
uh,
standard classical economic ideas.
And that's where sometimes people get a little
bit tripped up where we had the calculus wrong,
but correcting the calculus is still based
within the universe of, of relatively standard
economic thinking.
So it's not really as outside of the box as
someone might think to say, Hey, instead of
sending shoes somewhere, let's help them develop
a shoe wear industry, for example.
That's still too standard for some people.
And so I think that yes, some of these ideas
are becoming more known, but these ideas,
you know, you said a bunch of hippies told
you this.
I don't know that it's actually hippy enough
to come to some of these realizations, if
that makes sense.
Well, that's kind of what I was interested
in because who has been making those critiques
in the past?
They have not been, uh, culturally in terms
of the United States, they have not been incredible.
But Richard Wolf has the academic credentials,
you know, Stanford and or, uh, and Harvard.
They can an hour multimillionaire, um, and
the new economic thinking people very, very
reasonable, very academically inclined.
And the, I'm, I'm interested in not just a
foreign aid, but that's my entry point into
critiquing kind of neoliberalism or, or new
conservatism that the market fixes everything
when in fact the market is, has been taken
over, yada, yada.
Well, one of the best examples of getting
away from that kind of thinking is as more
and more people realize that the healthcare
system is broken, they are realizing that
the market can't take care of everything and
some things need to be out of the market and
out of the for profit sort of sort of status
quo.
Um, and that's a, that that's, that's a great
thing to be realizing.
All right.
Thank you so much for the call.
I've got a bunch of people holding, so I am,
I, uh, I'm going to let you go, but I hope
to hear from you again.